hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section 5 of
David Humes inquiry concerning human
understanding after bringing up the
issue of belief and what belief is and
how the sentiment or feeling of belief
is is so important to it and makes it
different than fancies or fictions which
are the action of the imagination things
that we actually do believe in what is
it that we feel or think when were when
we're believing in something he then
talks about the different principles or
modes of Association and now he's
already been discussing one at great
length in this section which was about
cause and effect and he said that it's
really reducible to constant or
customary conjunction and he's defying
the nature of customer habit in
producing belief but then he asks well
what about other kinds so what are the
principles of connection or Association
he says we can reduce these two three
resemblance contiguity and causation and
he tells us these are the only bonds
that unite our thoughts together and
beget that regular train of reflection
or discourse which in a greater or
lesser degree takes place among all
humankind so these are the three main
way
days in which we connect our ideas
together and move from one which is
present to another which is absent
bringing them into you could say our
purview and these are all about what
Hume calls matters of effect so do these
he says provide belief he said he asks
does it happen in all these relations
that when one of the objects is
presented true the senses our memory the
mind is not only carried to the
conception of the correlative but
reaches a steadier and stronger
conception of it then what otherwise it
would have been able to attain steadier
and stronger conception is one of the
ways in which he has characterized the
feeling or sentiment of belief in the
truth or reality of that thing so he
says this seems to be the case with that
belief which arises from the relation of
cause and effect but can it be the same
with other relations or principles of
Association if so he says this may be
established as a general law which takes
place in all the operations of the mind
what would that mean not only that we
have belief going on but that we have
this force of customer habit taking
place in relation of resemblance and
contiguity as well as causation so this
is a very important transition and Hume
examines this by considering some
examples and we might come up with many
other examples on our own but I think
for the time being we should look at his
so he says our first experiment the
appearance of the picture of an absent
friend our idea of this person is
evidently enlivened by the resemblance
and that ver every passion which that
idea occasions whether of joy or sorrow
acquires new force and vigor in
producing this effect he says there
occur both a relation and a present
impression what's the present impression
looking at the picture and we don't
necessarily need to have you know like a
snapshot that we keep on our desk
although people do that right why why do
people keep pictures of their loved ones
on their desk or their dogs and cats
couch could be loved ones as well right
so that they can be reminded so there we
have the impression all right and then
we have the relation and what is the
relation the relation is that of
resemblance the image resembles the
person and this is why you know there's
a side note we can have such discordant
experiences like for example you bring
somebody in and you've got an old
picture of them and you're like you
don't look anything like your picture
well there's a lack of resemblance there
they've gained weight they've lost
weight their hair is turned white you
know they had a beard they've shaved it
off they were wearing a cowboy hat
whatever it happens to be right
resemblance is is something that we are
looking for there so that can produce
not only this understanding that that
you know there's a connection between
these things but also sentiments in
ourselves so we look at a picture of the
person who we love or the friend or
somebody like that and then we feel warm
fuzzies unless maybe it's a picture of
them being devoured by a lion and then
we feel bad we feel sad right
we could have pictures of our enemies
and look at them and be like ooh angry
hatred right any of these are possible
we can even have pictures of somebody
who's boring and leaves us feeling kind
of blase and we look at it when I have
that's that person you know what totally
makes sense so he says in producing this
effect there's there's a relation and a
present impression where the picture
bears the person no resemblance at least
was not intended for him it never so
much as conveys our thought to that
person so you know think about bad
drawings right we have our kids in
school make drawings of mommy and daddy
and whoever else right and it's
basically like a bubble head with two
eyes and a mouth and a nose and stick
figure things and we know because the
kid has told us well that's mommy
stadi that little you know Susan over
there that's the dog Rover that what
these things are supposed to represent
but if you were to take somebody else's
kids pictures and put them in front of
you and be like any resemblance there
you'd be like resemblance to what other
ball-headed
you know skinny stick figures I don't
know any of them in real life what is
this supposed to be so that if the image
doesn't convey an adequate resemblance
it's not going to have this connection
that draws us from the image to the
thing so he says where the image is
absent as well as the person though the
mind may pass from the thought of one to
the other it feels the idea to be rather
weakened rather than enlivened we take a
pleasure in viewing the picture of a
friend when it is set before us but when
it is removed we choose to consider them
directly rather than by reflection on an
image which is equally distant and
obscure and this is something that we
can think about even more in our
incredibly image rich world of social
media and streaming video and all these
other things at the time he also talks
about religious ceremonies Hume likes to
pick on the Roman Catholics being in
Scotland at the time where the
Presbyterians are the establishment and
the rest of England is more or less
against the Roman Catholics within you
know Ireland and bit in Scotland in
England but mostly in other countries
like Spain in Italy he has a ready
audience for this sort of thing and he
talks about the ceremonies of the Roman
Catholic religion what are they doing
there he says the devotees of that
superstition usually plead an excuse for
the mummeries with which they are
operated that they feel the good effect
of those external motions and postures
and actions in what enlivening their
devotion and quickening their fervor so
the idea is that by engaging in the
rituals and we could apply this to just
about anybody you connect those rituals
by resemblance to whatever it is that
you're supposed to be keeping in mind
right it could be like having a
relationship with with some divine
person or object or principle and we
don't need to go further but you see how
that would how that would work
resemblence clearly does provide belief
right this is stronger sensation than
mere fiction
what about contiguity contiguity is
being connected in space and time she
has a really great example here he says
considering the effects of contiguity it
is certain that distance diminishes the
force of every idea and upon our
approach to any object though it does
not discover itself to our senses it
operates on the mind with an influence
which imitates an immediate impression
so what is he what is he saying there
we're moving along in space and time as
we get closer to something that we can't
yet see or experience but we see things
that are connected to it in space and
time our mind is drawn to that and it
can have an effect on us we might you
know feel fearful getting closer to home
or we might feel joyful or whatever it
is and we could think of other things
too like getting closer to school like
you're driving along and if you don't
particularly like being say in high
school and you see that the streets that
are like coming up to it you're like ah
crap another day of you know drudgery
here and in this high school or you know
if you really enjoy being in school you
might be riding along and you know it's
raining but you can still make out that
you're getting closer you're like hey
school time so wonderful all right you
know this is part of what goes on when
we take trips so he says that here we go
the thinking on any object readily
transports the mind to what is
contiguous what is what is connected to
it in space and time but is only the
actual presence of an object that
transports it with superior vivacity
when I am a few miles from home whatever
relates to it touches me more nearly
than when I am 200 leagues distant
that's 600 miles though even at that
distance there reflecting on anything in
the neighborhood of my friends or family
naturally produces an idea of them but
in the latter case where I'm imagining
it there's an easy there's an easy
transit transition between them that
transition alone is not able to give a
superior vivacity for want of some
immediate
impression right so as I'm actually
getting closer to home and seeing things
and smelling the air of home I am more
drawn to it and I'll tell you it about
an experience that I had that was quite
interesting along those lines so when we
were coming back from Spring Break some
April early April from Florida to
Wisconsin we would take you know very
long route it was about 24 hours drive
to get from where we were in Florida up
to to where we were in Wisconsin as
we're passing through Northwestern
Indiana things started to become dead we
were transitioned from a space of you
know quick clear spring and even like
getting ready for summer in the south
what summer to us in the north right to
things being gray and brown and drab and
tan
you know nothing was fully in green
bloom as we went further and further
north right and it was interesting
because as we did that I remember
thinking to myself we're home we were
still two states away but that's the way
things were for the most part at that
time of year in my home and so seeing
that drab dreary landscape filled me
with a sort of joy that being in the
south and you know seeing everything
green didn't so it's clear that
resemblance and continuity both helped
to produce the vivacity of belief in
there what Hume calls connected or
conjunct 'add items or ideas
he points out a really key feature here
he says that we may observe in these
phenomena the belief of the correlative
object is always presupposed without
that the relation could have no effect
so if I don't have some actual friend
who could have died but existed at some
time to have a picture of then that
picture is not going to have the effect
it'll have some effect but it won't
the effect the same effect that this
this connection of belief does right so
when we when we put together pictures of
people who we don't know or watching
movies of people who we don't actually
you know we kind of lend credence to the
existence of the character but we're not
completely right it's not the same thing
as seeing a documentary like holy crap
look at what happened to those people
you know there there's a difference for
him between those and he says that the
influence of the picture supposes we
believe our friend to once have once
exists existed contiguity to home can
never excite our ideas of home unless we
believe that home really exists or
existed as well I mean I can have all
sorts of beliefs about things in my
childhood home which are no longer there
in the present you know the hill behind
our house that we used to play on all
the time it's been cut down right now
house has been put at it the meadows
where we used to play as kids all gone
as well then turned into a subdivision
as the farmer sold off the land but it
did once actually exist so we can have
that velocity and you could say we can
think of it this way you need to have at
least some belief content or energy or
feeling in order to get it anywhere else
once you've got it then you can work
with it in that system how do you have
some examples here that are that are
kind of nice dry wood he says when I
throw a piece of dry wood into a fire my
mind is immediately carried to conceive
that it augments not extinguishes the
flame all right
the transition of thought from the cause
of the effect proceeds not from reason
it derives its origin from custom and
experience and we could say that belief
is active in all of this unless you've
never actually done anything with a
campfire in which case you don't
actually have that until you get a
little bit of experience putting wood in
the fire and he talks about sword and a
wound you don't necessarily have to have
had the experience of somebody poking
you with a sword you've probably been
punctured by something else at some
other time that drew blood
and you can you can say oh man the this
is an even bigger needle I'd better
watch out for that so all three of these
principles on Association are active in
how we move from one thing that we have
belief in to another thing that we then
can have belief in or vice versa and all
three of them are going to be absolutely
integral in how we understand what
humans calling matters of fact things in
the world things that have to do with
our own emotions or passions and things
that have to do with our relations with
other people
you